much so with that let's bring in michael
berry general counsel for first liberty
institute which filed the lawsuit on
behalf of these service members he's
also an afghanistan war veteran and a
member of the marine corps reserve who's
asking for religious exemption to the
vaccine mandate himself so
michael berry thank you and thank you
for your service and good to have you
here so so the legal battle here is
really one versus one of freedoms under
the constitution and versus readiness
which the pentagon says is the reason
that they want
all members to be vaccinated right
that's right martha and you know first
liberty institute just won this really
first major victory against the vaccine
mandate across the nation
we're really thrilled with the outcome
and just as you said look if the
military is really concerned about
accomplishing the mission and readiness
and force and strength then why are they
kicking people out why are they kicking
out navy seals who should be fighting
for our freedoms and fighting to defend
this nation instead of fighting for
their jobs that's un-american and it's
unconstitutional as the court held
yeah you know i want to play the sound
bite from john kirby who was
representing the other side or speaking
on behalf of the other side here's what
he said
religious exemptions
for medical
military medical requirements are just
they are typically historically very
rare
i can't speak to each and every case
again i'd point you to the
services
but this has absolutely nothing to do
with uh with trampling on the religious
liberties of our men and women in
uniform but you argued otherwise michael
that's right first liberty institute
argued in court and and the court held
that that's exactly what this is it's
trampling all over the constitutional
rights of our service members when the
military allows
hundreds possibly thousands of medical
exemptions administrative exemptions uh
but doesn't grant a single religious
exemption the only word to describe that
the only way to describe that is that is
just blatant religious hostility it's
unconstitutional it violates federal law
and again we're thrilled that the court
agreed with us and ruled against the
navy and against the department of
defense and we'll see where it goes from
here but martha we look
people's need to read this decision it
is a powerful decision it's available at
first liberty.org people need to read
for themselves this is a blueprint for
how to fight this vaccine mandate the
proper way especially for those who have
a religious objection just like our
clients do and what was their primary
religious objection if you can sum it up
well i mean 35 different navy seals
you're going to have 35 you know
individualized that's the whole point of
this right every person has an
individual religious belief and has the
right to have that religious belief but
many of them they object to the the fact
that the the vaccine was tested or
developed or produced using aborted
fetal cells others just simply prayed to
god they earnestly prayed to god and
said god what do you want me to do and
god said no all right i do not it would
violate their conscience and their
religious convictions to get this
vaccine and under the law that is
absolutely protected in this country
you know and i've heard the point
brought up about general george
washington at valley forge and how he
wanted all of his troops inoculated
against smallpox he did make an
exception for people who had already had
it which i thought was interesting um
what about that precedent
oh well you just said it yourself that
they'll that president washington
general washington at the time even
understood that there was such thing as
natural immunity our pentagon doesn't
seem to get that they they have made no
allowances for natural immunity they've
made no allowances for people with
sincerely held religious beliefs and
that's what our constitution in federal
law requires so
and talking about historic precedent you
know let's talk about uh desmond doss
medal of honor recipient who was
threatened with court martial because of
his religious conscience and objection
to having to carry a weapon and use a
weapon in combat and our military found
a way to allow him to serve with his
religious beliefs and his conscience
intact and he went on to receive the
medal of honor our navy seals deserve no
less than that they can continue to
serve this country as they have and to
defend our freedoms i mean they're navy
seals for crying out loud they're the
some of the most elite warriors we have
we need them we need them fighting for
our freedoms not fighting for their
careers we're grateful for their service
that is to be sure and for yours as well
sir michael berry thank you thanks for
being here today